Sending astronauts to space used to take a
computer the size of a washing machine.
Now?
That same computational might can be packed
into something as small as an iPad!
But as we aim for smaller devices, we're hitting
a threshold...our current materials and techniques
may not allow us to continue to progress at
this pace.
Because of this we’re being pushed in new
and exciting directions, like innovating the
very stuff computers are made of: goodbye
silicon, hello gallium oxide.
Traditionally, computer chips have been made
out of silicon--hence the name ‘silicon
valley’.
A computer chip transistor needs to be conductive, because it needs to be able to pass electric
current through the chip, but it also need
to be able to turn off that current easily,
so that it can send both messages: yes and
no, 1 and 0.
These kind of materials are called semiconductors
because they can be either a conductor or
an insulator when needed.
Silicon happens to be the most abundant semi-conductor
on Earth.
But we’ve pushed silicon almost to its limit
in terms of small we can get it.
We’ve hit the threshold of Moore’s Law:
the idea that the number of transistors we
can fit onto a computer chip doubles every
year.
That was first posited in 1965 and has held
more or less true over the decades.
It’s meant that computing power approximately
doubles every two years.
But now, approaching the edge of Moore’s
law has meant a flurry of exploration into
what comes next...
A paper published earlier this year outlines
a case for Ga2O3, or gallium oxide, which
may be the semiconductor we’ve all been
waiting for.
One of the properties that makes this material
exciting is its large ‘bandgap’.
See, semiconductors have their unique properties
because of their bandgap, which is the distance
between their outermost band of electrons,
called the valence electrons, and the conduction
band, which is where the electrons jump to,
when excited, to form an electric current.
So silicon and gallium oxide are both semiconductors
with ideal bandgaps to use in computing, but
gallium oxide’s bandgap is larger.
This gives it a uniquely high ‘critical
field strength’ and a broad range of possible
conductivities, ultimately making it a better
future candidate for computer chip scalability.
This field is brand new, like a couple months
ago new, but we think all of these properties
mean that you could fit more gallium oxide
transistors onto a chip than silicon transistors
AND this new material could potentially improve
the efficiency of future high-power electronics.
These discoveries are still very much in the
experimental stages and the potential real-world
applications remain to be seen.
Research like this, into new materials and
techniques, promises hope.
It’s not just new materials in the same
computing methods.
It’s also completely new methods of computing
like quantum computing and optical computing.
The upside of being backed into a corner by
Moore’s Law it that it forces us in new
directions and into exciting boundary-pushing
territory.
Want to keep pushing those boundaries with
us?
Subscribe to Seeker!
And for moore on moore’s law, check out
Trace’s video, here.
Fun fact: The original computers used by NASA
in the 70’s were kept cool by a substance
that was also used in blood substitutes for
medical uses.
Weird. I’m Maren, thanks for watching Seeker.